[Musique]
c'était il y à très très très longtemps
en ce temps là il y avait le ciel à
droite du ciel il y avait la planète jbe
elle était complètement plate et elle
penchait soit d'un côté soit de l'eau à
gauche du ciel il y avait la planète
shadoks
elle n'avait pas de formes spéciales ou
plutôt elle le changer de sens au milieu
du ciel il y avait la terre qui était
ronde et qui bougeait sur la terre il
n'y avait apparemment rien
sur la planète jib il y avait des
animaux qui s'appelait jbe voici un jbe
vu de près en voici un autre quand il y
avait trop de lipides à côté
la planète pencher
les jb glissé il y en avait qui
tombaient c'était très gênant et surtout
pour les idées sur la planète shadoks
il y avait des shadoks de deux sortes
des shadoks avec des pieds en bas qui
vivait au dessus de la planète et des
shadoks avec des pieds au qui vivaient
de l'autre côté et qui servait à
soutenir la planète par en dessous
comme la planète j'adore changer de
forme il y avait des shadoks qui
tombaient c'était très gênant surtout
pour les shadoks les shadoks élégie be
en y ont donc assez au bout d'un certain
temps de vivre sur deux planètes que ne
marche pas bien alors ils décidèrent les
uns et les autres d'aller sur la terre
qui avaient l'air de bien marcher
les shadoks élégie bis qui vivent sur
des planètes différentes ont décidé
d'aller sur la tête mais ce n'était pas
si facile que ça oui oui les shadoks
ressembler à des oiseaux il avait un
deck date et l'heure elle était ridicule
non minuscule
au début les shadoks pour dde ordinaire
mais comme il avait de trop longue pas
de ces deux là se cassaient maintenant
les shadoks pondent des oeufs ont fait
y'en a deux sortes les yeux avec les
pieds en bas et les hauts avec les pieds
au c est là on les envoie de l'autre
côté de la planète
les shadoks sont excessivement des chats
chaque fois qu'ils essaient d'aller sur
la terre avec leurs petites ailes
évidemment ça tu les shadoks élégie bis
qui vivent sur des planètes différentes
ont décidé d'aller vivre sur la terre
les jib y étaient de petits animaux très
gentil avec un petit chapeau sur la tête
pour pouvoir se dire bonjour et il était
très très intelligente pour aller et sur
la terre ils ont construit une fusée
elle fonctionne grâce à un combustible
superpuissant le cosmo girls 999
dès qu'il y aura suffisamment de
combustible l'affairé jbe pourra partir
mais quel est ce combustible miracle
d'où les jbe l'extrait t-il comme vous
le savez la planète jbe etp l'acte dès
que l'on creuse un trou retombe de
l'autre côté les gy be ne peuvent donc
rien extraire du sous sol sans cela leur
planète serait une vraie passoire cjd
extrait le cosmologue 1999 de
l'atmosphère
celle ci est recueillie dans d'énormes
jantes aulnoye atmosphère
et puis pompée dans des pompes à
atmosphère et par un procédé secrets et
les jbe on extrait le cosmo gun brut di
cosmo goal de première pression qui une
fois raffiné concentré et enrichit donne
le fameux cosmo gun 999 qui propulsera à
la fusée jbe mais les jbe pourront-ils
produire assez de cosmo goal pour
arriver sur la terre avant les affreux
shadow propulsé par un combustible
miracle le cosmo gaulle 999 extrait de
l'atmosphère
la fusée des jbe va partir pour la terre
sur la planète shadoks les shadoks
essaie de construire une fusée
interplanétaire mais ils sont en retard
sur leurs programmes et le professeur
shadow qu est inquiet
il observe les progrès de la fusée jbe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelque temps après le ch et les jib il
usine à cosmo goal subitement saft la
teneur en cosmo gold tombe
mystérieusement assez au parc elle
scélérate en jean un château compte il
anéantit les réserves de cosmo goal et
réduit la fusée jbe à l'impuissance
sous la direction du professeur jadot co
les shadoks ont construit une fusée
interplanétaire mais il restait un
problème
les shadoks n'avait pas de carburant
suffisamment puissant pour subtiliser
celui des jbe le cosmo gaulle 999 le
professeur shadow coûts avaient mis au
point un plan d'avancé bordeaux qui
était sur lui même de nous dire deux
mots de ce plan c'est très simple pour
que le cosmo gun jbe viennent chez nous
il suffit que nous le confions
[Applaudissements]
et nous le pompon grâce à cette cosmo
pompe de mon invention une puissance
incroyable de 3 millions de shadocks
vapeur c'est pourquoi toute la
population shadoks pompait pompait
pompait tu
il pourrait dans la joie il est fait on
allégresse
mais pour le moment dans le vide car le
cosmo cops tardait à se manifester
il y avait quelque chose qui n'allait
pas dans le plan du professeur shadow
quo n'est quoi les shadoks n'avait pas
de carburant assez puissant pour faire
partir leurs fusées alors ils essayaient
de pomper le cosmo gun jbe à travers le
cosmos et s'imaginer que par la simple
force aspirante de leur machine
le cos moghol consentirait à traverser
des espaces infinis du cosmos mais le
cosmo gaulle ne l'entendaient tout
simplement pas de cette oreille
les atomes de cosmo goal était des
atomes très lourd et très sérieux qui ne
changeait pas de planète comme ça pour
un oui pour un non et les dérisoires et
ford c'est pitoyable baisse n'a fait
pratiquement aucun effet le cosmo gun
restaient suspendues dans le cosmos à
quelques encablures de la planète jbe
mais dès que les efforts des shadoks sur
la chaîne soit qu'ils à l'ass se coucher
soit qu'ils tombent à s'épuiser
le cos moghol repartait et tout était à
recommencer
certes les jbe s'inquiétait au début de
voir leurs atmosphères allait venir
comme ça sans rime ni raison alors ils
braquent air leurs antennes de
télévision et quand ils virent les
shadoks sur leur télévision une cure
plus inquiet du tout
il disait
laissons faire les choses de toute façon
les shadoks sont idiots leurs plans
ratera et cetera et cetera et l'egypte
ils décidèrent d'aller en vacances à la
campagne
en attendant que le plomb shadow crac et
que les shadoks cela à ceux de pont pic
ce qui ne pouvait garder
en attendant que les shadoks se lasse de
pomper et que le plan shadow crac et que
le plomb shadoks rate les gy be sont
partis en vacances à la campagne
il en profite pour se faire de nouveaux
costumes
il faut dire qu'en ce temps là quand ils
voulaient changer de costumes les jbe
mangèrent 6-1 jbe manger des fleurs
ça me faisait un costume à fleurs
si un autre jbe préférait les petits
pois le lendemain hop
il avait un petit ensemble à pois
quentin jbe manger un jour par exemple
des carottes
le lendemain par exemple rien du tout un
jour des carottes un jour rien du tout
[Musique]
ça lui faisait un très joli costume rayé
angie be s'amusait s'amuse elle
s'amusait tandis que pendant ce temps là
les shadoks eux tous des pontets pompey
il pompait le matin il faut bel après
midi ils pompaient le soir et quand ils
ne pouvaient pas ils rêvaient qu'il
pompe est ce qu'ils revenaient
exactement aux mêmes qu'à la cosmo pompe
avait été spécialement étudiée
mais plus ils pompaient plus il n'y
avait rien qui sortait et le professeur
shadow qu était inquiète d'autant plus
que la planète shadoks recommencé à se
déformer et donnait des signes de
désagrégation imminente
chez les shadoks c'est la panique leur
planète est en train de changer de forme
comme nos téléspectateurs le savent la
planète shadow qui était soutenu dans
l'espace par des shadoks spéciaux avec
des bâtons ou et qui empêchaient la
planète de tomber mais ces châteaux
klein n'avait aucun sens de leur
responsabilité et il arrivait même à
certains d'aller se coucher
de sorte que quand il était sur le dos
leurs pattes ne soutenait plus rien du
tout et la planète aussitôt se déformer
ou bien pour protester ils se mettaient
tous du même côté et la planète devenait
alors pratiquement inutilisable
quand on se dit qu'on est en ville ou
sur une route par exemple la route
pouvait tout à coup devenir un escalier
ou n'importe quoi
ils étaient obligés d'avoir des vélos
spéciaux avec des roues de formes
diverses
pour faire face à toute éventualité de
même quand il monte un escalier il
n'était jamais sûr d'arriver en haut ils
ne savaient plus quelle était des
escaliers qui montent et et ceux qui
descendait et sauf quand s'étaient
expressément écrit dessus
alors il arrivait souvent qu'avec un
escalier près loup pour la montée on
réussisse à monter plus bas qu'on ne
serait descendu avec un escalier prévu
pour la descente
dans ces conditions la logique shadok ne
reposait pas sur des bases solides ce
qui nuisait considérablement au
développement normal de leur
intelligence et spécialement en matière
de fusées interplanétaire chez les
shadoks rien de nouveau ils pompaient
toujours mais plus ils pompaient
pompaient pompaient plus leur moral
pessey baissait baissait
et malgré les efforts du professeur
château cos épuisé tombé par milliers
alors le chef shadoks flanqué de son
fidèle sorcier fit venir château cos et
lui parla en ces termes
[Musique]
et le film est trop roulant il faut dire
que le groupe était une sorte de trou
dans lequel on entassait les shadoks qui
n'avait pas donné entière satisfaction
l'appelait aussi quelquefois enfer à
cause que ceux qui étaient dedans y
était enfermée
comme l'egypte il avait prévu le plan
shadow karaté le cosmo go les revenus
des ibis dépêche de rentrer de vacances
ils font le plein de leur fusée si bien
qu'en moins de rien ils sont prêts à
partir pour la terre tout était il perdu
pour les shadows peut-être pas car le
sorcier veillait et attendait son heure
la pompe à cosmo goal est arrêté les
shadoks épuisé refuse de pompey mais il
restait le sorcier en ce temps là en
effet sur la planète shadoks il y avait
un sorcier
il s'occupait plus spécialement
d'astrologie et c'était lui qui par
exemple était chargé tous les matins de
faire le soleil se lever
ça lui prenait le temps qu'il fallait
mais tous les jours il y arriver et à
cause de cela les shadoks le respecter
et l'adorait comme tout seul une et
c'est quand même pas mal de temps libre
entre deux il était plombier
ils détecter les fuites d'eau et des
bouchers les lavabos il disait aussi
qu'il disait l'avenir dans son robinet
magique et le chef shadoks lui-même
venaient le consulter souvent sur des
problèmes de gouvernement ou des
problèmes de robinets c'est ainsi que
prenant la direction des opérations
le sorcier installe son robinet sur la
peau à cosmo goal est dit que fois de
sorcier on verrait ce qu'on verrait et
que le cos moghol sortirait de son
robinet sortira-t-il sortira t'il pas le
sorcier shadoks a installé son robinet
magique sur la pompe à cosmo goal et les
shadoks repompe comme d'habitude car tel
semblait être la destinée de ces
pitoyables bête pomper pomper pomper mai
ducos moghol il ya longtemps qu'il n'y
en avait plus pour la bonne raison que
les jib y avait tout extrait et avait
fait le plein de leurs fusées et tout
était prêt pour leur grand voyage sur la
tête mais avant de partir
et en guise d'adieu à leur vieille
planète
clac il avait organisé une grande fête
[Musique]
ouais ils s'amusaient comme des fous
pendant tout le jour et le soir
regardez des shadoks à la télévision et
libye en guise d'adieu à leur vieille
planète plate faisait des feux
d'artifice et lancé des confettis
[Musique]
mais les confettis étaient aussitôt
aspiré par la pompe shadoks
[Musique]
le de voeux pour biais du pari qui
pointait sa pop du cosmo gun crier
victoire dit ouah le cosmo girls est
arrivé et les shadoks sans précèdent
entassés des confettis dans leur fusée
comme le précieux combustible atomique
et j me trouvais ça très amusant de voir
leur confettis aspirer ils ont relancé
et il en relançait et plus les givi
s'amusait plus les shadoks pompey et
plus les confettis n'arrêtait pas darryl
les jbe en profitèrent pour faire un
grand nettoyage de leur planète et se
débarrasser de toutes sortes d'ordures
gênante tels que papiers gras pot de
yaourt peau de banane et quantité
d'autres détritus ce
[Musique]
les shadoks prenait tout ça pour un
précieux combustible atomique et on
entassait le plus possible dans le
refuser
c'était il y à très très très longtemps
en ce temps là il y avait le ciel au
milieu du ciel il y avait la terre et
sur la terre il n'y avait rien ou
presque rien
la population de l'inter comptait
quelques bestioles pas très réussis
comme le gorille but le lapin poisson et
le minet qu'en top espèces qui étaient
en voie de disparition rapide plus
certaines insectes du nom de gégène et
qu'ils n'avaient pas l'intention de
disparaître du taux comme nous le
verrons paradis à gauche du ciel il y
avait des shadoks et la fusée shadoks à
droite du ciel il y avait les jbe et la
fusée jbe comme nos téléspectateurs le
savent
l'egypte y avait un petit chapeau sur la
tête et c'était là le secret de leur
intelligence quand un jbe réfléchissait
à quelque chose d'un peu compliqué hop
il mettait ça dans son chapeau sa passe
est automatiquement dans les autres
chapeaux et tous les gimmicks mettait à
réfléchir ensemble sans qu'on ait besoin
de leur explique pour la nourriture
il n'avait pas de problème non plus il y
avait des gibiers apple des gia lai et
des gibiers un fromage c'est dire que
pour aller sur une planète même
lointaine les jbe n'avait pas besoin
d'en porter autre chose que leur chapeau
et tout ce monde-là voulait aller sur la
terre
réussiront ils à partie arriveront-ils
même sur la terre que sont ils devenus
aujourd'hui les shadoks ont compté les
détritus des jbe et veulent s'en servir
comme combustible pour leur refuser les
shadoks étaient venus nombreux assister
aux premiers essais quand leurs fusées
[Musique]
l'évasion shadoks notes avaient revêtu
leurs combinaisons spatiales
[Musique]
ces malheureuses bêtes n'avait pas de
connaissance spéciale en astronautique
d'ailleurs elle n'avait pas tellement de
connaissances spéciales on peut même
dire qu'elle n'avait pas de connaissance
du tout choquée c'est la fusée retombées
et se cassait
si bien qu'à la fin ils essayèrent de
faire partir leurs fusées à la main mais
il ne se passera rien non plus il ne se
passera rien comme ça pendant un certain
temps et même davantage
pendant que les malheureux shadoks
essaie en vain de faire partir leurs
fusées à la main les jbe finissent
d'aménager la leur
la fusée jbe comportez pas malde étage
d'abord un premier étage propulseur
contenant le combustible libye d'une
puissance infinie le cosmo goal 999
aux étages supérieurs ont trouvé une
piscine chauffée entièrement aménagé
une salle de jeux avec balançoires
patins à roulettes jeu de dominos et
autres appareillages hautement
perfectionnées indispensable pour
survivre sur l'écorcé terrestre
un étage carnaval avec manèges montagnes
russes et autres instruments de
navigation indispensable pour la même
raison un étage campagne avec des fleurs
des arbres des petits ruisseaux et des
jardins potagers ou les gibiers cultiver
des légumes est nécessaire pour subvenir
à leurs besoins techniques moteur
électrique et ionique microphone en
grappe gyroscope possible de télévision
et dans les vergers
ils poussaient des antennes radar des
gôniots m et des radiotélescopes tous
ces instruments la donner et des graines
que l'on récoltait et qu'on voulait on
fabrique et il suffisait de les semer
dans des endroit adéquat
c'est dire qu'avec le nom les jbe
pourrait faire de la terre une planète
très confortable les cosmonautes shadoks
continuent leur vol d'essai sous la
direction technique du devin plombier il
travaillait en étroite collaboration
mais on voyait bien que ça risquait de
durer
le marin shadoks qui regardaient ça
disait même que la fusée ne partirai
jamais c'était un ancien quartier maître
pirate qui avait mal tourné
contrairement aux gens de son espèce qui
passe généralement leur tend à
introduire des petits bateaux dans une
bouteille lui il introduisait des
bouteilles dans son petit bateau il
permet par maxime et quelquefois mais
mon anglais c'est lui qui disait par
exemple
dans la marine on ne fait pas grand
chose mais on le fait de bonheur et en
effet il partait dès potron minet soi
disant pour aller voir où était le vent
mais le soir quand il revenait il avait
complètement oublié et il disait qu'il
était saoul influence en réalité d'été
tout simplement pris de boisson pour la
fusée il disait que le plus simple était
encore d'aller subtilisé la fusée jbe
que lui connaissait le chemin et que lui
il irait l'a subtilisé lui et en bateau
finalement c'était insensé mais comme il
était un peu trop souvent sous
l'influencé et qu'il constituait un
objet de scandale
le chef shadoks lui donna quand même
l'autorisation
en fait il se disait que c'était un
moyen simple et les gants de s'en
débarrasser le pauvre marin pourrait-il
tenir son pari et traverser le cosmos en
bateau
le marin shadoks a décidé d'alléger les
jbe en bateau à travers l'espace pour
subtiliser leurs fusées ils mettaient la
dernière main à une caravelle
interstellaire de sa conception et il se
dépêchait de peindre tout ce qu'il
pouvait car disent-ils dans la marine
c'est un principe il faut saluer tout ce
qui bouge et peindre le reste jour du
départ de grandes réjouissances avait
été organisée et quand la shadow
caravelle fut inaugurée
on vit sortir du moule aps quelques
intrépides de shadocks qui furent
invités à ramé est il parti
[Musique]
oh
puis aussitôt d'un prêt sans perte de
temps inutile procéda à une autre
inauguration celle d'une magnifique
statue où on pouvait lire anneaux hardy
marins perdus dans le cosmos parce qu'on
savait déjà qu'il ne reviendrait pas
mais ces malheureuses bêtes
elle n'en savait rien et su préserver
laisser partir c'était explique mans
pour s'en débarrasser car de long il n'y
en avait pas tellement
et au bout d'un certain moment nous elle
s'arrêtait après quoi il n'y avait plus
rien sauf évidemment le néant
chez les shadoks la situation est
satisfaisante
les essais de fusées continue à très
bien rater car c'était un des principes
de base de la logique shadok ce n'est
qu'en essayant continuellement que l'on
finit par réussir ou en d'autres termes
plus ça rate plus on a de chances que ça
marche
et comme il voyait justement que les jbe
ne faisait aucun essai de fusée
il était persuadé que ce serait te les
shadoks qui seraient les premiers sur la
terre et qu'elle leur appartiendrait il
commençait donc à essayer très tôt le
matin les essais ratait d'abord pendant
toute la matinée
quand tout allait bien on arrivait à en
raticide quelquefois set mais c'était
rare vers midi il prenait un repas léger
ça continuait ensuite jusqu'à la nuit et
le lendemain de très bonne heure il
recommence
l'egypte vit à l'autre bout du cosmos
continuer tranquillement à surveiller
leur jardin et à récolter des graines de
moteurs électriques et de beaucoup
d'autres choses pour les emmener sur la
tête et le soir comme d'habitude on
entend des chants il regarder où les
shadoks en été mais maintenant c'était
beaucoup plus amusant car depuis que le
marin shadoks étaient partis en bateau
dans l'espace
il avait deux programmes et il s'il en
avait assez de voir les shadoks raté
leur essai il regardait les marara mais
quand il avait vu que ces innocentes des
et espérait arriver chez eux pour leur
voler leur refuse la paix d'abord cru
mourir de rire
puis il avait décidé de lui laisser
faire car douze utile ça valait la peine
de regarder de plus près des animaux au
suraigu pendant que les essais shadoks
continue à rater les gy be surveillent
leur jardin à instruments et vous l'êtes
emporté les haines d'instruments pour
les replanter sur la terre et en
attendant auquel mûrissent pour passer
le temps ils le regardaient les essais
shadoks ratés et les essais de fusées
shadoks comporter plusieurs farce
d'abord les techniciens chats 2 cantonne
le compte à rebours sur un vieil air
d'accordéon
[Musique]
e
non
[Musique]
et puis les shadoks les plus doués pour
les mathématiques enfourchent leur
ordinateur à pédales pour calculer la
toile c'étaient eux qui a fait le plus
de mal qu'à les shadoks avait entendu
dire que plus un ordinateur va vite plus
il donne de bons résultats et c'est
celui qui avait gagné qui avait trouvé
la bonne trajectoire
on procédait alors à la mise à feu sarah
thé yupps itw après on recommençait
naturellement on pourrait continuer
comme ça pendant longtemps mais les
marins shadoks sont partis en bateau
dans le cosmos pour conquérir la planète
jbe voyons un peu où ils en sont eh bien
il ramait sous le commandement de
principe du pirate shadoks qui comme à
l'ordinaire était assez joliment a pris
de boisson
[Musique]
si bien que personne en fait ne regarder
où on allait mais ils disaient qu'ils
ont la marine c'est l usage et qu'il est
beaucoup plus intéressant de regarder où
l'on ne va pas
pour la bonne raison que là où l'on va
il sera toujours temps d'y regarder
quand on y sera
et que de toute façon ça ne sera jamais
en fin de compte que de l'eau sauf
nature et moi prévu or un jour justement
un marin s'écria plus doux c'était vrai
et ils ne pouvaient plus avancer
le marin shadoks avait observé que l'eau
à l'avant des bateaux avaient souvent
tendance à se transformer subitement
iceberg en cailloux en baleine ou même
en rien du tout mais il avait remarqué
aussi car l'arrière des bateaux il y
avait toujours de l'eau qui ne servait à
rien et pour continuer d'avancer il
ordonna que l'on récupère c'est aulas
pour la mettre à l'avant de sorte que
pendant que des shadoks d'en haut a
mellow ceux d'en bas la récupérer pour
que ce drôle la ram
c'était un système de navigation ingénue
méprisant et on pouvait se demander si
les valeureux marins pourraient aller
comme ça jusqu'à l'autre bout du cosmos
le marin shadoks est arrivé à l'endroit
du cosmos où il n'y a plus d'eau il
avance quand même
mais comment c'est qu'en ce temps-là on
pouvait aller en bateau dans le cosmos à
condition d'en porter son nom
[Musique]
mais malheureusement par endroits le
cosmos était percé le long fatalement on
en perdait et quand il n'y avait plus
d'eau on sombrait pour la remplacer
il fallait apporter d'énormes provisions
d'eau et souvent il y avait plus d'eau
dans le bateau que sous le bateau
si bien qu'il y avait des shadoks qui
périt s'est noyé sans même que le bateau
coule
c'était pas très confortable mais
c'était pourtant comme ça que les mains
shadoks avancé elle croyait ces naïve
bête traverser tout l'espace
interstellaire est débarqué chez les
gibiers en catimini pour leur voler leur
fusée mais il y a longtemps que les
jubilés voyez venir et ils avaient
décidé de leur jouer un tour pour que
les malheureux marin continue à ramer
comme ça pendant tout de l'éternité et
même peut-être plus les jbe se prépare à
faire face un débarquement de shadocks
sur leur planète mais vous direz vous si
les shadoks pouvait aller au bateau de
la planète shadoks à la planète jbe
pourquoi n'allait-il pas directement et
par le même moyen sur la terre à cela il
y avait deux raisons la première relever
du second principe fondamental de la
logique shadok qui disait pourquoi faire
simple quand on peut faire compliqué la
seconde relevait de lois cosmiques
beaucoup plus sérieuse c'est que pour
aller sur la terre il aurait fallu
monter et que si on avait monté l'eau
aurait coulé et très rapidement ils
n'auraient plus
les jbe qui les voyaient arriver se
disait jeumont le retour
camouflant notre planète tirons des feux
d'artifice
il faut dire que l'egypte y avait des
feux d'artifice spéciaux et qui faisait
de l'obscurité et quand on est y joue on
n'y voyait plus rien et de nuit ils
faisaient encore plus de nuit
et des shadows nous voyons que de
l'obscurité conti terreur à mai vers les
espaces extérieurs et apparemment infini
du cosmos
ils rament air longtemps longtemps
longtemps
il le sait puisaye dépérit désespéré
puis se pardonner leurs péchés et le
marin shadoks lui même noyé sa peine
dans une sobriété exemplaire
mais un jour un pauvre marin s'écria la
planète jbe la planète jbf tu le voyais
là vous le savez ça n'était pas la
planète jbe c'était quoi
les marins shadoks perdu dans le cosmos
ont vu quelque chose au bout de l'infini
et qu'ils prennent pour la planète jbe
mais il faut savoir qu'on ce temps là le
cosmos n'était pas tellement infinie que
ça il n'était d'ailleurs pas infinies du
tout et pour tout dire il était plutôt
rond de sorte que quand on partait d'un
endroit et en allant tout droit au bout
d'un certain temps
on ira arrivait pour aller quelque part
en général le plus simple était encore
de partir de là où on voulait aller et
avec du temps et un peu de chance on y
arrive est effectivement mais les
shadows que n'était pas au courant de
tout ça et au prix d'incroyables
sacrifices ces malheureuses bêtes allait
arriver là d'où il était parti c'était
leur planète qu'il prenait pour la
planète jbe avec d'infinies précautions
il débarque nuitamment chez eux pour
s'emparer de leurs fusées ils la
transporte en catimini sur leur bateau
et repartent comme ils sont venus mais
en sens contraire évidemment le lot
demain matin les shadoks qui venait
comme d'habitude en faire de nouveaux
essais de fuser sur d'abord étonné puis
il crié victoire victoire note refusé
marche enfin elle est partie et les
mêmes partait tout seul la seule chose
que ces pauvres bêtes avaient oublié
malheureusement c'était de maux de dos
comme le kosovo sur ce temps là et héron
les marins shadoks croyant débarquer
chez les jib y ont débarqué chez eux
voler leurs propres fusées et sont
repartis au bout d'un certain temps
naturellement il re débarquèrent chez
eux
mais comme il faisait encore un peu nuit
ils retournèrent se coucher en attendant
d'être reçus triomphalement les shadoks
voyant leurs fusées revenus crièrent
victoire victoire note refusé match
elle est partie toute seule elle est
revenu tout seul et il s'empressèrent de
l'art transporter de l'autre côté pour
posséder un continent à de nouveaux
essais les marins en se réveillant
crièrent à l'abordage
à l'abordage les ribinou trahis ils ont
repris leurs fusées et il repartir
aussitôt pourra chercher il fab sans
dire que la chose duras comme ça pendant
assez longtemps
et pendant que c'est pitoyable bestioles
tourner tant qu'on l'egypte y cultivait
tranquillement leur jardin et récoltait
des graines du sinn pour les emmener sur
la terre et comment ils plantaient d'une
graine du sinn la terre se transformer
petit à petit on ce qu'il fallait que
tout cela se relier où se relier pas
selon ce qui est écrit dans la graine
est au bout de temps autant de saisons
elle donnait selon les cas me des
bananes des montres suisses nous des
noix de coco des barres de fer ou des
bulldozer mais un moment l'egypte y
s'arrêter et crié ces landais shadow
oxelo de ce dock il courait au bord de
la planète pour les voir passer d un
jour malheureusement le jeu c'est ça les
shadoks ne passèrent pas et les gibiers
était un peu triste car il commençait à
s'y attacher qui étaient devenus les
pauvres marin shadoks les jib y sont
inquiets ils ne voient plus sur leur
télévision les marins shadoks tourner en
rond dans l'espace que sont ils devenus
et bien voilà une nuit comme d'habitude
les marins shadoks avait débarqué chez
eux pour s'emparer subrepticement 2
fusé il avait eu beaucoup de mal pour la
ramener à leur bord car la nuit était
noire et la mer apparemment avait montée
ils avaient été obligés d'escalader
l'eau pour monter dans leur bateau mais
plus ils rament air plus il restait au
même endroit et au matin ils y étaient
encore
il s'était tout simplement trompé de
bateaux car comme vous le savez les
shadoks persuadé que les marins à l'est
vers leurs pertes leurs avait à l'avancé
ériger un monument et il s'était frotté
dedans quand les autres shadoks boillon
leurs fusées revenus soit plus montèrent
thalasso pour essayer de la récupérer le
marin shadoks lui criait à l'abordage à
l'abordage les jbe nous attaquent
car il croit dès qu'il avait affaire à
des jbe déguisés et les peurs ford et le
combat efira pendant des jours et des
coucous périssaient d'autres étaient
plus ou moins définitivement estropiés
n'est qu'ils allaient gagner
les marins shadoks ont embarqué sur leur
statut au lieu de remonter dans leurs
bateaux les autres sont montés à
l'assaut
la bataille fait rage
bonjour
aux pauvres bêtes les marins se
défendirent d'assez galamment mais à la
fin il succombé sous le poids d'un
adversaire très supérieur en armement et
en os et on leur dit que ce n'était pas
parce qu'ils étaient revenus qu'elle
allait démolir est si jolie monument
qu'on l'a déconstruit et ce n'est pour
eux et qu'il était de leur devoir
les marins de disparaître effectivement
et ce le plus définitivement possible
[Musique]
alors le marin shadoks se fit corsaire
de l'espace est dit que fois de shadocks
et fois de marins ils reviendraient
et qu'il se vengerait pour répondre à la
demande de ceux de nos téléspectateurs
qui n'ont pas eu la chance de suivre
notre feuilleton cosmique
depuis le début nous allons résumé la
situation
nous avons à droite du ciel la planète
plate dgipi quand elle était trop lourde
d'un côté le punch quentin jbe aller
d'un côté il fallait et qu'il y en est
un autre qui avec de l'autre côté à
gauche du ciel nous avons la planète à
shadoks
elle n'était pas pratique non plus elle
avait tendance à tomber par le bas il y
avait d'une part des shadoks ordinaire
avec des pâtes en bas il n'était pas
excessivement intelligent et il y avait
d'autre part déjà des coups spéciaux
avec des pâtes en eau
il n'était d'ailleurs pas plus
intelligente pour ça mais il s'il
n'avait pas été là il n'y aurait rien eu
pour soutenir la planète dans l'espace
et et leur est complètement tombé mais
de ces shadoks là il n'y en avait pas
partout et là où il en manquait
s'affaissait et les shadoks eux aussi
voulaient aller sur la terre leur fusée
n'était pas prêt présent points mais il
avait calculé qu'elle avait quand même
une chance sur un million de marché et
il se dépêchait de bien rater les
ou 999 1999 premier essai pour être sûr
que le millionième marche avec ce genre
de raisonnement typiquement shadoks mais
pauvre n'était pas prêt le parti en tout
cas pas comme ça les shadoks continue a
raté le plus possible décès et plusieurs
fois par jour en automne le compte à
rebours au son de l'accordéon
m
tout cela évidemment faisait pas mal de
bruit et les chats dr bah tu comme vous
le savez soutenait la planète s'en
plaignait il disait que sa maison peut
se réfléchir qu'elle en avait eu assez
et que c'est tout ça ne s'est pas j'irai
tout se couche et qu'ils ne
soutiendraient plus rien du tout et que
la planète qui braie c'était de
l'intimidation pur et simple car il
savait très bien que si la planète
tombait je serais tombé avec et ça ne
les intéressait pas tellement elle
protestait quand même pour les apaiser
les shadoks d'en haut et est obligé de
le renvoyer d'énormes quantités de
nourriture par des petits conduit
spéciaux creusé à cet effet mais plus on
leur en donnait plus ils ont demandé
[Musique]
et quand il n'y aurait plus rien à
manger les shadoks dans ba protestent
les essais de fusées font trop de bruit
à leur avis ça les gêne c'était pourtant
une fusée de l'ups
elle avait un premier étage bourré de
détritus qui devait en principe servir
de combustible un deuxième étage bourg
et d'autres détritus indispensable pour
vivre sur la terre et dans les
interstices
on avait les châteaux
elles étaient munies il des derniers
perfectionnements techniques telles que
casseroles à retardement
le batteur d'air et et tire bouchon
hypersustentateurs la seule difficulté
c'est qu'elle ne marchait que d'un côté
de haut en bas uniquement
c'est pourquoi les shadoks a pensé qu'il
serait intéressant de faire porter la
fusée dans l'espace par les shadoks d'en
bas il avait déjà soutenu la planète
pendant pas mal de temps et porter une
fusée à côté c'était rien qu'ils disent
ce drôle le allait envoyer dépit des
potentiels pour négocier la terre et les
avaient fait descendre par les petits
qu'on dit se drape adaptant s'était
trompé les avez mangés puis il avait
répondu tout de même pas là pour porter
leurs affaires leurs casseroles leurs
armoires l'heure d'été pull et fusées
partie le marché de toute façon qu'ils
disaient ils avaient l'intention de
rester ici pour être enfin tranquille
en réalité c'était pas vrai eux aussi
avaient l'intention de déménager sur la
terre mais par quels moyens
pendant que les shadoks et les antis
shadoks régler leur histoire
la fusée des jib y est parti ça s'était
passé un matin sans difficulté
[Musique]
et les jib y découvrir l'espace avec ces
planètes et ses paysages en ce temps là
il n'y avait pas mal de choses à voir
dans l'espace
et comme il n'était pas très pressé il
avait décidé de faire un peu de tourisme
cosmique
[Musique]
quand il trouvait un endroit qui leur
plaisait s'arrêter pour pique-niquer ou
bien mieux ouvraient leurs fusées et
donner des représentations
il faisait ça uniquement pour s'amuser
car le plus souvent il n'y avait
personne pour les regarder mais
quelquefois si caen mais il y avait les
poissons de la planète à poisson par
exemple qui grimpaient dans leur arbre
pour les regarde
il faut savoir qu'en ce temps-là les
poissons avait des petites pattes et se
promenait dans les arbres aussi
facilement que vous et moi les jbe les
avait fait tellement rire qu'ils en
avaient versé des torrents de larmes
et quand l'egypte y avait dû partir il
en avait versé d'autres encore si bien
que les arbres avaient été obligés et
nager et c'est depuis ce temps là que
les arbres nage et les poissons aussi
d'ailleurs
les shadows que d'en bas à eux aussi ont
décidé d'aller sur la terre pourrait
être tranquille jusqu'ici vous lirez
vous nous avons laissé ses chats doc la
faire un peu ce qu'ils voulaient sans
trop nous en occuper et nous prions nos
téléspectateurs de nous en excuser
mais il ne se passait déjà tellement de
choses en eau que nous n'avons pas eu le
temps de voir ce qui se passait en bas
eh bien il s'y passe est à peu près la
même chose et si vous voulez le savoir
en détail il nous suffirait de
recommencer notre histoire à partir du
début et de vous remontrer tout comme ça
mais quand même pour résumer simplement
les choses disons que d'une part leur
eau à eux était plus bas que le bas de
ceux d'en haut et que d'autre part leurs
bas étaient excessivement au dessus de
leurs eaux de sorte que quand un shadok
d'en bas voulait tomber d'assez haut par
exemple il fallait qu'ils sautent de
bien plus bas que si le haut avait été
nettement au dessous c'est à dire en
réalité au dessus du bas ou quelque
chose comme ça pour le reste c'était
paraît et pour partir il avait construit
devinez quoi une fusée évidemment mais à
l'envers
restait à savoir si une fusée comme ça
accepterait de marché à l'envers dans un
espace à l'endroit où inversement les
shadoks que d'en bas on construit une
fusée pour partir tout seul de leur côté
cbs scélérate n'avait absolument aucun
sens moral
elle voulait partir pour que la planète
ton
et pour voir la tête que ce dont on
ferait quand il se révélerait avec rien
sous les pieds mais il a fait les mêmes
problèmes que ceux dont à l'envers
évidemment et si la fusée de ne voulait
pas monter celle d'en bas elle refusait
de descendre et un chaque essai elle
remontait et se casser il avait fait
appel pour la fabriquer un spécialiste
que justement des fusées cassante
le professeur shadow qu'on lui même que
vous connaissez bien il avait déjà conçu
la fusée dans mo et il s'est est une
parfaite réussite du point de vue
cassage il faut dire et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il était au groupe
vous vous souvenez que le groupe était
une suite de boyaux étroits ou les
shadoks dont on n'était pas
excessivement satisfait étaient invités
à se reposer mais les shadows lambaye
avait creusé des sortes de petites
trappes qui l'ouvraient de pauvres et de
pouvoir les autres tombées ce qui les
amuse et passablement des shadoks drogba
naturellement et ils avaient déjà
beaucoup qu il leur fallut les plots de
sa fusée sinon il le ferait sortir eu du
boulot et pas du bon côté
jadot coup évidemment avait cédé mais
tout seul lui avait donné une idée les
expériences de fusée et se poursuivre
sous la direction du devin plombier au
le professeur chats 2 co qui était au
goal peu comme on le sait criaient à
travers les barreaux qu'il avait une
idée géniale
le chef shadoks le fit sortir et dit
qu'il s'occuperait de la fusée en
étroite collaboration avec le plombier
la concurrence se disait-il
les stimuli et nuit pendant ce temps là
il pourrait retourner se coucher
le devin plombier se servaient
exclusivement dans ses expériences
scientifiques de son robinet magique
et que la terre était d'un côté lui avec
son robinet il aboyait pas rond et et il
disait que la fusée il fallait donc bien
la faire mon temps certes ajouté t-il
on risquait de retomber au long était
mais ça valait quand même la peine
d'essayer
je le connais un télescope tellement
usés que quand on regarder trop loin
avec les rayons se cassaient de sorte
que lui ils vivent la terre par rabat et
il disait que la fusée il suffisait
simplement de le laisser tomber
certes à tempe et ils ont risqué de ne
pas aller exactement là où l'on voulait
ou d'aller là où ne voulait pas mais on
était sûr au moins de ne pas revenir où
il en est
et comme justement la fusée ne voulait
pas beau ça prouvait bien que c'était
son clan à lui qui était le nom lequel
des deux avait raison
les jb continue tranquillement leur
route vers la terre et s'arrêtent de
temps en temps pour visiter le cosmo le
cos nous c'était un peu comme une
campagne ordinaire sauf que
naturellement où tout était cosmique
il y avait des arbres cosmique
desbuquois cosmique des cascades
cosmique et des quantités de choses
cosmique comme ça et puis un jour en
rentrant et ils s'aperçurent qu'il y
avait un jb y manque
il était plus simplement rester dans les
champs cosmique à s'amuser ils disent
que lui
les histoires de voyages de fusées de
planète
tout ça ça l'intéressait pas que lui il
voulait vivre sa vie de gy be et qu'il
voulait rester ici mais le malheureux
avait perdu son chapeau le chapeau des
jbe vous le savez ça leur servait à
réfléchir et un gimmick avait perdu son
chapeau pratiquement c'était un gimmick
avait perdu la tête
il avait fallu faire entrer de force
mille c'est fini a tout saccagé dans la
fusée il se faisait de la soupe avec les
réserves de graines de gyroscopes et
deux moteurs électriques et ils se
mettaient à tourner à tourner soit
disant pour faire de l'électricité pour
le faire tenir tranquille on l'asseyait
devant la télévision et il regardait les
shadoks
aussi bizarre que cela paraisse sans le
calmer mais c'était quand même pas une
solution
l'important c'était de lui retrouver son
chapeau mais où avait il bien pu
l'oublier
jadot quoi trouver que pour faire partir
la fusée il suffisait de la laisser
tomber
alors les shadoks par kt c'est décidé
heureusement qu'ils partent d'ailleurs
car depuis le temps qu'on en parlait
nous commencions à nous impatienter et
bien non il ne partira pas encore cette
fois
figurez vous que tout à coup les shadoks
et leurs ustensiles surpris d'étranges
convulsions il se tordait se déformer
puis maigri et les godets et à la fin
disparaissait il avait attrapé la
maladie
c'était
la maladie cpt cosmique qui se promenait
dans les espaces interstellaires et
surveiller quand il y avait des choses
qui ne lui plaisaient pas ou qui la
gênait l arrivée et n'entendait plus
parler
or les shadoks justement ça ne lui
plaisait pas tellement des animaux aussi
mal en pis si des disait on ne veut pas
eu de fabriquer des choses comme ça on
ne va tout de même pas perdre son temps
elle a surveillé des bêtises pareilles
alors les malheureuses bêtes terrassé
par le terrible
léo disparaissaient les unes après les
autres
bientôt il y en aurait plus la fin des
chagos peut être avait sonné la
situation se complique
les shadoks sont malades et dépérissent
l'egypte y ont des problèmes avec un
autre vie qui est malade dans la tête
depuis qu'il a perdu son chapeau
[Musique]
[Rires]
pour le calmer
on le mettait bien regarder les shadoks
à la télévision mais tout le monde sait
qu'il est très dangereux de regarder la
télévision sans sa peau et à force voilà
il se prenait pour un château voilà qui
s'étaient déguisés en château voilà je
suis camara que tout ça c'était de la
mauvaise graine et compagnie qui disait
et voilà qu'il voulait retourner le voir
son père sa mère et tous ses petits
cousins la bras sur la planète shadoks
il avait pris les commandes du fou
en retrait son ballon sur les systèmes
solaires et passait le mur de la lumière
[Musique]
il faisait dérailler les trains
d'antimatière et effrayer les troupeaux
de nébuleuse qui s'enfuyaient dans des
longs mais là bas sur la planète shadoks
la terrible maladie les attendait
qu'allait-il se passer les shadoks sont
en train de disparaître
ils ont attrapé la maladie qui fait
rétrécir en ce temps là c'était facile
il n'y avait pas 36 maladie il n'y avait
la maladie qui servait pour tous pour
les pieds au lait donc pour la tête et
même pour l'intérieur quand un shadok
marché dont la maladie avec ses pieds ou
d'un conte lot qu'il se rétrécissait et
quand il marchait du côté où il y en
avait moins ils seraient précisés mois
de sorte qu'il serait prêt si c'est pas
partout de la même façon
c'était amusant ses pattes d'abord se
tordait où se ramollit c'est la pauvre
bête se traînait lamentablement coussins
et puis au bout d'un certain temps les
intérieurs étaient attaqués le chat d'oc
tout entier se grattait maigrissait
maigri nf1 disparaissait le de 20 points
bien aux principes les réparer avec son
robinet magique qu'ils disaient
[Musique]
en réalité les jetait tout simplement
courte
le professeur shadow coup de son côté en
profiter pour me faire de la concurrence
il avait soi-disant mis au point un
vaccin ainsi maladie mais les shadoks
inoculé sur le fleix se gonfler et à la
faim éclater c'était encore plus
accusant la retenue d'eau mais du point
de vue de la santé
si cela continuait le problème du voyage
sur la terre faute de voyageurs allait
être définitivement résolus la planète
shadoks est infestée par la maladie
cosmique les uns rétrécissent des autres
grâce aux vaccins du professeur shadow
qu éclate
pendant ce tour dans le cosmos le jpy
son chapeau pilotait la fusée comme un
fou sans s'occuper de rien et foncer
droit sur la planète shadoks et la
terrible maladie
malheureuse sonnait toujours pour un
chat d'oc et voulait retourner dans sa
famille il voyait des lumières sur la
planète shadoks et ils croyaient qu'on
tirait des feux d'artifice pour
l'accueillir
[Musique]
c'était pas ça du tout c'étaient les
shadoks inoculé qui éclatent est de loin
bien sûr ça faisait bien mais de près
quel beatty la maladie d'abord les
contaminer les réfléchissez ils ne
mouraient pas tous mais ceux qui
survivent est le professeur fin de
compte je t'aide celui pour les inoculé
les shadoks évidemment essayer de se
cacher ils se camouflent et en importe
quoi en passoire
[Musique]
en ressort deux lits au poêlon arrosoir
pour échapper au terrible fléau
hudak sage profession shadow co mais
rien n'y faisait et la maladie pour les
uns comme pour les autres la situation
dans son ensemble commençait à être
assez désespérée la situation est
désespérée
les jbe vont tomber dans la maladie les
shadoks pour y échapper se déguise en
passoire où on ressort de lits mais la
maladie venait à bout des ressorts
s'infiltrait dans les passoires les plus
étanches s'infiltrait dans le groupe
découvrait d'énormes réserves de
shadocks qu'elle rétrécissait beaucoup
périr et nourrit du shadow que la
maladie redoublé de vigueur et de
méchanceté si bien qu'à la fin la
planète elle-même se mit à rétrécir
d'autres péri mais voyez comme les
choses sont drôlement c'est le ji me
fous dans la fusée voyons que la planète
rapetisser crier mais je le recul je
recule et il a versé des commandes si
bien qu'ils se mettaient à reculer pour
de vrai et l'egypte y furent sauvés mais
pour les shadoks c'était autre chose
les pauvres bêtes panique il sautait
dans la puce et sans même contre le
temps de se changer
les shadoks d'onde a sauté dans la leur
or la fusée d'euros qui était alors
droit ne marchait pas à l'endroit
tandis que la fusée dans le bac était à
londres et ne marchait pas à l'envers
c'est à dire que dans une certaine
mesure elle marche est alors en droit et
d'autres sont encore ceux qui tombèrent
descendants essayer de s'agripper à ceux
qui tombèrent en montant bien il se
hissait sur les ustensiles qui flottait
entre temps à force de manger trop de
shadocks la maladie était tombé malade
et les sa partie des rescapés et les uns
ont tassé dans des tiroirs les autres
dont des casseroles ou des passoires
c'est ainsi que commença pour eux le
long et pénible voyage qui devait en
principe les amener sur la tête
[Musique]
la planète shadoks a été rétréci par la
maladie les shadoks font route vers la
terre entassés dans leurs ustensiles
venait d'abord le chef shadoks dans sa
casserole personnel plus de 20 plombier
dans son lavabo et le professeur shadow
co le reste de la population suivait et
comme elle pouvait il y avait des
shadoks en boîte des châteaux quand
casserole ou à la poêle et même des
shadows quand tu évidemment il était un
peu à l'étroit mais il avait quand même
du choix car quand un château qu'on
avait assez de vivre dans un tiroir du
haut par exemple ils pouvaient
s'installer dans un tiroir du bas et
même vice et versa mais tout était plein
de shadocks et pour la cuisine c'était
pas pratique quand on voulait faire
cuire des nouilles par exemple il
fallait déménager les shadoks qui
habitait dans le fourneau en attendons
les installer dans l'aude et nous
qu'en sais tu es cuit et des ménages et
des shadoks qui habitait dans la
passoire et on les mettait dans le
fourneau ont passé une première fois
pour récupérer l'eau dans le tourneau
ont passé une deuxième fois pour
récupérer les nouilles apa enfin au
passé le fourneau
récupérer l'eau à ce moment là les nous
tomber et on pouvait recommencer quand
il y avait vraiment trop de shadocks
dans les ustensiles en ange dette pour
cool mais depuis qu'il avait plus de
planètes
le groupe n'était plus qu'un ton avec
rien autour et les chats d'un contrô se
mettait à tomber ou à tourner autour des
planètes continent passait on les
appelait des satellites et c'est depuis
ce ton là d'ailleurs qui l'y attend de
satellites dans l'espace le triste
cortège des shadoks avance péniblement
dans le cosmos le plus grave problème
reste celui du logement le moindre fait
un repas c'est qui flottait le moindre
fil de fer devait en supporter des
centaines et ça souvent sur plusieurs
étages il y avait des shadoks qui
servait de plafond des shadoks qui
servait de plancher à ceux qui servent
et plafonds et des shadoks qui servait
de cloisons et dans les interstices
laissés libres la vie à bord petit à
petit s'organiser elle s'organisait mal
mais elle s'organisait tout de même
pendant ce temps là naturellement il se
reproduisait
[Musique]
à
alors il en tombe est bien sûr mais il
n'en tombe est pas du tout suffisamment
et la nourriture manquent et certains
essayer de pêcher des choses dans le
néant donc désespérément j'ai les
ustensiles kiné supporters
[Musique]
plus il avançait plus il on tombait les
jbe de leur côté continuer à sillonner
l'espace pour retrouver le chapeau du
libye fou il avait ce truc est partout
avec leurs radars mais ils n'avaient
rien trouvé
et eux aussi commencer à désespérer
entassés dans leurs tiroirs
interstellaire des shadoks sont sur le
point de mourir de faim les jib y sont
toujours à la recherche d'un chapeau
perdu dans le cosmos il faut savoir que
les chapeaux des jib y était un peu
comme des téléphones mais est tellement
perfectionner qu'il n'y avait même pas
besoin de parler de dents il n'y avait
qu'à penser issa émettait quentin jbe
par exemple avec une musique dans la
tête tous les autres jbe pouvait écouter
[Musique]
ou bien ils n'écoutaient pas ça dépend
des or un jour c'était le chapeau perdu
qui se remettait à heml 3 il y avait
quelque part dans l'espace
quelque chose qui pensait avec nos
chapeaux bibis sur la tête et qui
pensait plutôt mal c'était un pauvre
chat d'oc affamés qu'il avait péché il
avait obtenu dire que les chapeaux bibis
servait pas réfléchir
il se prenait bourrage haddock
intelligent il dit c'est qu'il pensait
les autres qu'il n'avait jamais vu ça
naturellement le croyait mairie chapou
dgipi marché dans les deux sens et il
cessé hier d'insuffler aux shadoks une
mauvaise pensée qu'il aurait pas pu la
voir à lui tout seul ça marchait alors
ils décidèrent pour passer le temps de
leur insuffler comme ça des quantités
d'autres mauvaises pensées amusante
un shadok à retrouver dans l'espace le
chapeau des jbe ceux ci en profite pour
lui insuffler de mauvaises pensées
il lui faisait voir la faire à droite
ils allaient tous à droite il y faisait
voir la terre à gauche et ils revenaient
tous à gauche à toute vitesse à tout
bout de champ il criait trt les autres
naturellement ne voyait rien mais vous
avez confiance
ils y allaient et quand il arrivait
loyer qu'effectivement il n'y avait rien
c'était quand même intéressant sauf que
barton pour ainsi dire dernier les
shadoks arrivé au prix d'incroyables
efforts de sacrifices et de souffrance
pratiquement au même les jbe s'était
arrêté pour les regarder
de sorte que partant de rien aussi il
arrivait en fait la même chose mais en
se donnant beaucoup moins mal il faut
dire et puis un jour le château se mit à
crier pour de vrai car en effet il
n'avait quelque chose de rond à l'avant
il était sauvé il avait là enfin devant
o2 cette terre qu'ils avaient ton
d'espérer et dans la solennité de leurs
il oubliait les peines endurées et en
profitait pour se pardonner les uns les
autres
leur méfait
et la terre grandiose et sereine
émergeait peu à peu de l'infini comme si
elle n'est c'est pour eux seuls rançon
de toutes leurs terres
[Musique]
les shadoks sont sauvés il arrive sur la
terre au fur et à mesure qu'ils
approchaient leur joie grandissait
quelques uns aiment moururent de joie
avant d'arriver et un beau matin il
atterrit paix il ressortir de l'autre
côté mais plus mouillé car évidemment il
s'était trompé
ce n'était pas la terre qu'ils avaient
là mais ce qu'on appelait autrefois la
planète à eau
la planète à eau étaient une planète
ronde est normal et sauf qu'elle était
faite exclusivement dont il y avait de
l'eau ou de l'eau on bat nm de l'eau au
milieu les arbres là où il y en avait
était évidemment obligé de nager
ça venait de très jolis fort et un poids
tic qui tenait debout sur l'eau avec eux
rien en dessous
[Musique]
[Rires]
et les poissons volants qui étaient les
seuls habitants de la planète
venez dans leurs branches pour se
reposer et s'amuser et les shadoks eux
ne s'amusait pas du tout il le passé
leur temps sous l'eau car ils étaient
persuadés qu'ils étaient sur la terre et
il essayait de la tournée il cherché
pendant assez longtemps
puis un jour le devin plombier puisque
la terre était par en dessous
il disait qu'il fallait simplement
prendre l'eau et la mettre à côté et que
lui avec son robinet magique et quelques
shadoks volontaire il en ferait son
affaire
[Musique]
les shadoks sont sur la planète à eau
ils croient que la terre est en dessous
il avait installé un système compliqué
de tuyaux pour pomper l'eau de la
planète et la mettre à sec
[Musique]
les poissons voulons au début je
trouvais ça amusant et venaient les
regarder et travailler loudun comptait
commencer à baisser et de l'autre il y
avait une petite planète qui se
formaient il pond père comme ça pendant
assez longtemps mais pas le plus petit
coup de terre n'apparaissait si bien
qu'à la fin ils perdent ils s'aperçurent
enfin qu'il s'était trompé et qu'il n'y
avait pas de terre il ne restait que les
poissons volants qui étaient pour ainsi
dire obligé de nager à pied sec et qui
n'était pas content du tout il allait
revoir les shadoks et en manger un
certain nombre puis ils exigèrent qu'ils
remettent leur planète là où il l'avait
prise et plus vite que ça
ai-je fait encore une fois se remirent
les shadoks ont pompé tout l'eau de la
planète à eau puis il la repompe pour la
remettre en place mon pays pour les
shadoks à la longue
c'était devenu une habitude c'est à la
pompe en effet que la plupart de leurs
travaux s'effectuent et ne sais c'est
que tu es pas ça demande quand les
shadoks eux se trouvaient devant un
grave problème est qu'il voyait pas très
bien commencé
eh bien ils pompaient de toute façon il
disait ça pouvait pas de lui il avait de
grosses pompes pour les gros problèmes
et des petites poupées pour les petits
problèmes
il avait mis au point aussi des pompes
spéciale pour les cas où il n'y avait
pas de problème du tout pour ceux de nos
téléspectateurs que la technique
intéresse disons que quand on pompait
avec ça non seulement il ne se passait
rien comme avec une pompe shadoks
ordinaire mais plus on comptait peu plus
il n'y avait rien qui se passait c'était
quand même une sécurité et dès que les
shadoks avait fini de pomper les gy be
leur envoyer des visions les shadoks
croyez voir la terre est illégal est en
réalité c'était n'importe quoi comme par
exemple la planète molle mais les
shadoks pensais que c'était uniquement
un problème de mou alors une pompe est
le mou avec leurs pompes à problèmes mou
et pendant que les shadoks aller comme
ça de fausses terme faut se taire les
jib y aller s'installer tranquillement
sur la vraie
pendant que les shadoks perdre leur
temps à pompe et n'importe quoi dans
l'espace
l'egypte se prépare à arriver sur la
terre car la terre approchait et
l'egypte y répéter la grande fête qu'ils
avaient organisée pour l'inaugurer
[Musique]
mais vu de loin la terre n'avait pas
l'air tellement tellement bien d'un peu
plus près ce n'était pas spécialement
mieux et de très près c'était encore
pire
pour ne rien vous cacher la terre ont ce
ton là n'était pas si amusante que ça du
point de vue des sept ont particulier
c'était pas du tout organisé et il n'y
avait personne pour s'en occuper
il reste bien quelques dinosaures en
retraite mais il disait que les fêtes et
tout ça c'était plus de leur âge et que
de toute façon était appelée à
disparaître
ce qu'ils firent en effet par la suite
comme chacun sait alors les gy be
décidèrent de remettre un peu d'ordre
dans tout ça et passer un premier coup
de peinture pour que ça fasse plus qu
ils en profitèrent pour repeindre aussi
des dinosaures qui le remercie beaucoup
de leur attention la terre comme ça a
été quand même peu plus présentable et
la grande inauguration pouvait commencer
la plupart des shadoks en tombant sur la
terre se sont cassés il leur en faut du
neuf pour conquérir la planète
alors ils décidèrent de pour des oeufs
de façon intensive et que tout le monde
d'ailleurs s'y mettraient car chez déjà
d'eau constant là pour tout vous avouer
qu'il n'y avait pas de shadocks madame
et de shadocks messieurs tout le monde
avait le droit de pondre des oeufs
d'ailleurs c'était facile pour pondre un
oeuf il suffisait simplement de compter
jusqu'à 4 c'est dire que c'était une
question d'éducation
ça avait quand même des inconvénients
surtout pour ceux qui étaient trop
éduquer quand les mathématiciens shadoks
faisait des calculs par exemple pas de 3
4 1 2 3 4
sans qu'il s'en rende compte il leur
arrive est un oeuf
c'est pourquoi les mathématiciens shadow
qu'en temps normal ne comptait que
jusqu'à 3 et certains même que jusqu'à 2
pour plus de sécurité
et puis quand il s'agissait de compter
les e et bien on pouvait pas savoir
parce que celui qui les comptait 1 2 3 4
1 2 3 4
obligatoirement répondait il fallait
qu'il y avait été un autre qui passe
dernier pour recompter lequel à son tour
etc etc
quand ils eurent pondu suffisamment aux
deux alors ils les équipes r et attendit
patiemment kids est close et veuille
bien parti reconquérir la terre
les chats 2 confondues de grandes
quantités de en arrivant sur la terre
ils attendent patiemment qu'ils aient
clause pour partir conquérir la planète
mais qu'il y avait un inconvénient c'est
que des shadoks vous le savez bondet des
oeuvres en fait il avait trouvé ce
astucieux étant donné que comme vous
avez de trop longues pattes les oeufs
ordinaire ce cas c'est d'un côté vision
offert évidemment c'était pratique mais
dans les côtes et pas tellement car non
seulement ne se cassait pas mais il ne
se cassait pas il ne se passait pas du
tout si bien que quand le c'était mieux
rappelle que soit le shadow qui tu es
dedans on ne pouvait pas sorti il
fallait avoir une clé que leurs clés à
eux c'est saab et scylla l'avait oublié
chez eux
ces deux spectacles vraiment affligeant
de voir ces pauvres bêtes qui pendant
des générations et des générations et
des données tant de mal pour réussir à
pondre des oeufs à kasab seul donner
maintenant 1000 points peu ce pour
essayer de les casser
c'est pour ça que c'est pitié et c'est
naturellement nous cassez pas mais le
plus choquant malheureusement il faut
l'avouer c'était le chat d'oc à
l'intérieur puis se cassait
alors on lui de couver leurs oeufs
normalement comme vous l'auriez fait
vous et moi les shadoks les mettait à
rouiller mais ça prenait japonais
pendant le temps est souvent le shadow
qui était déjà très vieux quand il
sortait et ça valait vraiment plus la
peine les jib y passe tranquillement
leur temps à peindre les arbres et à
chanter des shadoks tant bien que mal se
sont multipliés et partent envahir la
terre les shadoks avait entendu dire que
la terre était ronde alors il avait
fabriqué des engins exprès
[Musique]
mais n'enterrons fin de course n'était
pas tellement que ça ou bien dans
certains cas il était non mais dans
l'autre sens pas et ça ne simplifie pas
les choses
il n'avait pas peur mais il était
prudent parce que il me évidemment il ne
savais pas du tout que d'étaler les jbe
les voyez ils se disaient ne nous
cachons pas trop la tête
les ont fait venir avec les shadoks kunz
et la bête mais ils avançaient atrides
et un jour il vit l'ennemi c'était des
arbres tout simplement ou des bouts de
cailloux qui dépassait mais les shadoks
étaient pas habitués ennemis bien sûr ne
pourrait pas mais c'était une ruse
évidemment il pensait alors les shadoks
beaucoup plus rusés se déguiser en
ennemis et bougeait encore moins ils
attendaient le temps qu'il fallait échos
l'ennemi siens témoins il sauté dessus
et le faisait prisonniers le jeu pouvait
durer assez longtemps d'autant plus que
dès que les vaillants shadoks avait le
dos tourné certains ennemis d'hafid que
profitait pour repousser alors les jib y
virent qu'ils y avait encore de beaux
jours à passer sur la terre tant qu'il y
aurait des arbres et des petits cailloux
pour tenir les shadoks qu'occuper
c'était il ya très très
très longtemps en ce temps là il y avait
la terre d'un côté de la terre il y
avait les gy be qui passaient
tranquillement leur temps à peindre la
campagne à chanter de l'autre côté de la
terre il y avait des shadoks qui
passaient leur temps à guerroyer contre
les arbres et des petits cailloux
[Musique]
et tout le monde apparemment était
content
au début de notre feuilleton nous vous
l'avions promis les shadoks et des jib
il devait arriver sur la terre et bien
les y voilà
et notre histoire pourraient s'arrêter
quand dans les belles histoires on
finirait en disant qu'ils furent heureux
et qu'ils devaient cure longtemps mais
ça serait vraiment trop abuser de votre
crédulité
car pour ne rien vous cacher c'est juste
au moment où notre feuilleton allait
s'arrêter
[Musique]
il est vrai en vêtements pour les uns
comme pour les autres allaient commencer
figurez vous qu'un jour les vaillants
shadow que s'apprêtaient comme
d'habitude à livrer bataille à un ennemi
très supérieurs en nombre et il en est
du gaullisme et qui est lui tout à coup
c'était terrible beit qui en ce temps-là
régna sur ma tête est les shadoks les
imbéciles à l'avait rêvé elle répondait
la bête au joli nom de gégène ou à
n'importe quel autre nom d'ailleurs mais
en général il valait mieux pas l'appeler
quand on vous disait que les vrais
embêtements allait commencer vous vous
rendez bien compte que ce n'était pas
uniquement une façon de parler alors
notre histoire finira plus tôt comme
ceci
c'était il ya très très très longtemps
en ce temps là il y avait la terre d'un
côté de la terre il y avait les jbe de
l'autre côté de la terre il y avait des
shadoks
entre les deux il y avait gégène la bête
qui les embêter et j'adore qu'il est
gibily revient au bout d'un certain
temps ne pourrais pas vivre longtemps
sur une terre dès qu'un gène comme ça
alors ils décidèrent les uns et les
autres d'aller sur la lune qui n'avaient
pas de gégène du tout
[Musique]